Gardiens, tout ce que vous aimez
sera détruit, allez
vous faire [ __ ], vous étirez le visage,
RoboCop a l'air
violet, nurple, paix, euh, vous
ne savez pas, vous pensez que les
Gardiens de la Galaxie vol 3 sont prêts,
les billets PG-13 jusqu'à maintenant, attendez,
attendez,
allons-y,
j'avais huit ans.  quand je l'ai quittée,
tu veux que je conduise, non, je vais
chercher comment le mettre en
vente à l'envers, maintenant, devinez quels
billets pour les fans de Marvel sont en vente en ce
moment pour les Gardiens de la Galaxie Vol 3.
ah, les Gardiens, êtes-vous prêts  pour une dernière
balade, votre groupe préféré de
héros Misfit est de retour alors qu'ils défendent la
Galaxie une dernière fois les enjeux sont importants, l'
action
et le courage sont
également importants, il a laissé de côté certaines
informations importantes, mais
c'est l'essentiel, achetez vos billets
maintenant pour Guardians of the  Galaxy vol 3
uniquement en salles le 5 mai